when Blade Runner came out in 1982 in
left fans speechless but it also left
them with a ton of unanswered questions
35 years later some of those questions
have finally been answered thanks to
Blade Runner 20 49 that's the good news
the bad news Blade Runner 20 49 has left
us with even more mysteries than before
here's a spoiler filled look at the
biggest unanswered questions in Blade
Runner 20 49 but I want to ask you some
questions
so is Deckard a replicant perhaps the
biggest question from the original Blade
Runner is whether or not Harrison Ford's
character the replicate hunter Deckard
is himself a replicant though the film's
suggested that he was it was
intentionally left ambiguous Blade
Runner 2049 takes that ambiguity and
uses it to totally troll the audience
with Jared Leto's replicate magnate
Wallace delivering a whole monologue
about whether or not Deckard is a
replicant without actually answering the
question this is one mystery it looks
like we'll never learn the answer to did
Kay die at the end of the film k lays
down in the snow to die in a beautiful
scene clearly meant as a callback to the
death of Rutger Hauer replicant leader
Roy batty in the original Blade Runner
there's one key difference however we
see Roy die on camera while Kay's fade
is left poetically and lyrically up in
the air sure he probably dies but the
Blade Runner films love leaving things
open to interpretation and Kay's death
scene is just another prime example
what's the deal with joy one of the most
enigmatic characters in the movie is joy
Kay's computerized virtual girlfriend
it's unclear whether she's a true AI or
just a sophisticated program designed to
emulate human emotions does she really
love Kay or is she just programmed to
pretend knowing the truth may answer the
other big question about joy how and why
did she end up bringing in mariette for
that super weird love scene it seems
beyond coincidence that joy happens to
contact the one replicant specifically
tasked with spying on Kay if joy truly
loves Kay then the explanation she gives
about wanting to experience physical
romance with Kay may be true but if
she's just a program you have to wonder
who programmed her to help the replicant
rebellion could she have been hacked by
them there's more to joy than meets the
eye but exactly what is anyone's guess
who put Anna's memories in Kay the
entire plot
hinges on the fact that K has memories
leading him to believe he's actually
Deckard son however it turns out that
while they're real memories they
actually belong to Deckard's daughter
dr. Anna Stellan who specializes in
creating false memories for replicants
considering she tells Kay that putting
real memories into replicants is illegal
it begs the question of why her memories
were recorded in the first place not to
mention how her memories happen to end
up in the exact replicant tasked with
tracking her down
perhaps if we knew how Kay ended up on
this case in the first place we'd have a
better idea but when the film opens k is
already tracking down the replicant
farmer sapper Morton who holds the key
to the mystery who told Kay about Sapir
and why coincidence or part of a larger
plot the more questions you ask about it
the more new questions it creates did
Anna know Deckard was her father so
about those memories Anna has she tells
Kay that her parents were ready to go
off world and put her in this bubble
when she got sick at the age of 8 to
protect her from the crappy world
outside that's clearly a lie though
because she has memories which have been
implanted in Kay about her time living
in the orphanage so what does she really
remember and what does she really know
about herself
the replicant rebel leader freiza played
by heum Abbas tells case she has
Deckard's daughter safely hidden away if
she's telling the truth it implies Anna
knows about the rebellion and her own
replicant parentage and is in on the
whole thing
what is Fraser telling the truth did
Anna know Deckard and Rachel were her
parents if the movie had gone on for
another 10 seconds we would have gotten
the answer but since it didn't we'll
have to settle for just guessing what
happens next at the end of the movie
humanity seems trapped between two
different replicant factions on one hand
Wallace wants to build replicants who
can reproduce allowing them to spread
across the galaxy on the other hand the
band of rebels responsible for hiding
Deckard's daughter want to rise up and
overthrow their masters if either of
these factions prevail Humanity has some
pretty nasty times ahead regardless but
what does happen Wallace is still alive
with all the resources of the solar
system at his disposal the rebels are
off somewhere making new eye patches for
their leader and the whole powder-keg
seems about to blow when the film cuts
to black looks like we'll have to wait
for Blade Runner 2079 to find out thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too
you